jacques chirac exprimé ses condoléances
aux familles des victimes
il a fait part de son émotion après les
conséquences dramatiques de la tempête
au nord de la loire tous les
départements en ont subi les effets le
point avec stéphanie perez des toitures
effondrées des voitures et endommagé des
arbres arrachés
partout le même spectacle de désolation
et de nombreuses victimes
ici à argenteuil deux personnes sont
mortes dans leur appartement
après la chute de la cheminée de leur
immeuble en tout 27 personnes au moins
ont trouvé la mort cette nuit et ce
matin en bretagne en normandie en ile de
france et dans le nord-est du pays le
plus souvent à cause de chutes d'arbres
on compte également deux disparus et des
dizaines de blessés c'est une tempête
que météo-france qualifient d'historique
un véritable ouragan s'est abattue sur
le nord du pays
c'est d'abord la bretagne qui a été
touchée vers 4 heures du matin puis
toute l'île de france
enfin l'est du pays avec des vents d'une
violence inouïe qui ont atteint jusqu'à
172 kilomètres heure à orly pour paris
on a relevé des valeurs devant qu'on
n'avait jamais vu depuis 50 ans ces
valeurs devant sont à peu près
comparable à celle qui a eu en octobre
87 dans l'ouragan qui avait touché la
bretagne à la normandie avec des rafales
de 60 60 ou 160 km h dans l'intérieur
des terres
ce qui est tout à fait exceptionnel pour
pour la france à l'heure actuelle entre
800 millions et 1 million et demi de
foyers sont toujours privés
d'électricité dans 70 départements
plus de trois mille techniciens edf
travaille d'arrache-pied le plan orsec a
été déclenché dans quatre départements
de l'est ainsi que le plan blanc en
meurthe-et-moselle qui réquisitionne les
personnels hospitaliers pour faire face
aux urgences
enfin à noter que le trafic sncf reste
très perturbé ce soir au nord d'une
ligne nantes nancy particulièrement
touché la région parisienne où les
dégâts sur la ligne sont très importants
de nombreux tgv en direction de la
capitale sont supprimés